to present the Oscar for film editing
here are two extremely well edited young
players who have recently returned from
filming in Italy this Angie Dickinson
and mr. rod Taylor
and gee I wonder why I hope that I made
a picture in Europe but he did rod in
London he just finished the road to Hong
Kong
oh well you just better keep away from
that road it's kind of trouble I said
we're never having been there
well we better get this Oscar on the
road the nominees for best film editing
are William H Reynolds for Fanny Alan Oz
Boston for the Guns of Navarone
Frederick Newton for judgment at
Nuremburg Philip W Anderson for The
Parent Trap
Thomas Stanford for West Side Story and
the winner auntie the winner is Thomas
Stanford for website
thank you thank you very much members of
the Academy the very company and
especially Bob wise and Jerry Robbins
for letting me do it in the first place
and for your unstinting support and
inspiration I'd also like to thank the
many others who contributed to the
editing of this picture
I feel very truly they share in this
great honor this evening thank you all